Jamie great musician that you must have
used your music at some times to woo a
woman happy I'll hit what I'll use
whatever I could put on my god no absent
like listen listen today this is one of
my favorite songs this is storm listen
to this listen how hot a lack of power
there's almost a spider-man link cause
it starts off with lights out like a
power outage lights out like a power
I could feel the mist every time we
kissed just didn't know it down for like
this desert there's a flash-forward
warning will it will rain in the morning
and they'll be puddles in the bed I want
to do the worthless there'll be puddles
in the bed the weatherman said yeah but
why were the puddles in the bed
listen girl I love Butler's girl the
weatherman said it's cloudy skies right
there between your thighs
I want it soaking wet all over the bed
do you sing lyrics Ibrahim a man
hey it sounds much better when you're
singing
it is very rare it is very rare for more
than one Spice Girl to appear together
for any reason at all did you ever ask
you a question like why are you there
why are you there why there is a purpose